I woke up like this flawless that's a
fiance says a new law makes California
the first state to ban discrimination
against black students and employees
over their natural hairstyles governor
Gavin Newsom signed the bill into law
yesterday it protects black people with
styles like dreadlocks or cornrows CBS
this morning Saturday Cohoes at 2:00
Michelle Miller is that essence festival
in New Orleans an annual Expo
celebrating black culture and music
Michelle what's behind this new law
Oh Gail good morning well the essence
festival this festival we're talking
about is all about empowering black
women not just in mind and spirit but in
how they wear their hair their crown
let's face it hair matters to everybody
but the authors of this new law say that
women with kinky and curly hair often
discriminated against viewed as inferior
even a dove recently sponsored a survey
that showed that black women were 80
percent more likely to change their
natural hair to conform to social norms
and expectations on the job so there are
a lot of folks who think this new law is
long overdue it had nothing to do with
the job I knew the job or you wouldn't
have hired me it just had everything to
do with my hair chastity Jones was
tangled in a nearly 10 year legal battle
after she says an employer took back a
job offer at an Alabama call center
because she refused to cut her hair she
said are those dreadlocks in your hair
and I just looked at her and I was like
these and she said yes I said yes they
are she said well we can accept that
here in 2013 Jones sued the company for
discrimination and lost wages but her
claim was dismissed last year the
n-double-a-cp filed a petition to bring
her case to the Supreme Court it
declined to hear the case she just
didn't make me feel like I was wanted
there period
she's not alone in August of 2018
Louisiana sixth grader faith finiti was
kicked off school grounds because her
braided hair violated school policy and
a few months later a wrestling official
told New Jersey high school athlete
Andrew Johnson he would have to cut his
dreadlocks in order to compete to make
sure our beauty is welcomed Dunc
executive AC eggleston Bracy spearheads
the crown coalition an alliance of
corporate and community organizations
whose goal is to highlight bias that
pressures women to conform to your
eccentric standards of beauty what
happens is your natural hair is one way
and you think you have to change that to
go into a work environment because the
view of what's professional is different
than what your natural state is and now
lawmakers are stepping in California
State Senator Holly Mitchell introduced
the first law to associate hair as an
extension of one's race which is legally
protected terminate it because of the
way they choose to wear their hair the
way my hair grows out of my head as a
black woman is a trait of race lawmakers
in New York and New Jersey have now also
introduced versions of the crown Act
California Governor Gavin Newsom says
he's proud to lead the nation by being
the first to sign it there's a human
element to this we don't want to
diminish people we don't want to demean
people we have to own up to the sins of
the past and I hope that folks are
paying attention all across this country
and New York could be the second state
to sign this bill into law
it's awaiting the governor's signature
and folks here at essence well they're
having a big celebration breakfast on
Friday the crown Coalition is meeting to
March this victory hopefully they say
into a national movement thank you thank
you very much definitely a topic I think
I know you yes we have expected
certainly do listen it's 2019 I don't
know too many little black girls I grew
up in Turkey and I can remember many
times there was three little black girls
in the class Oh
being asked can I touch your hair you
know just we all had the two braided
pigtails or three braided pigtails being
asked can I touch your hair because
they'd never seen anything like it
that's why I like crown creating a
respectful and open world for natural
hair yeah you think this is a good idea
- I do I'm shocked that actually there
were people losing jobs and yeah and
having because being up being asked to
cut their hair before they can compete
in this day and age it's just surprising
to me I guess way to express yourself
yes and like you said I think there's
sort of an ignorance about you know your
hair especially if you're
african-american I remember being in
school and people saying why don't you
wash your hair everyday yeah use grease
yes so it is an open conversation that
needs to happen so people are more aware
and sensitive to this and they make
certain assumptions based on your hairdo
which also many times are not valid
correct this is good crown creating a
respectful and open world for natural
hair done California grew up in Turkey
we're gonna talk about that some future